all right so who is better mystique
Rekha Rebecca remains Stamos or Jennifer
Lawrence okay this was answered really
well by Dario I don't know how to
pronounce that last part but I think the
Jennifer Lawrence was a much better
mystique because she was more dynamic in
terms of her character
Rebecca remains Stamos was a great
mystique for a character that didn't
really have any line so it didn't really
talk she wasn't very dynamic she was
really kind of there as a support
character as a leading role character I
felt like Jennifer Lawrence didn't much
better because Jennifer Lawrence was
able to bring a whole new kind of
dynamic she brought a lot of personality
and we really kind of saw the struggle
that her character was going through as
she was really kind of going through
this internal debate between whose
philosophies were right the philosophy
of magneto in the sense that mutants
need to strike first while the iron's
hot so they don't end up with a date of
Future Passed kind of a scenario or
Charles Xavier who has this peaceful
coexistence kind of ideology between
humans and mutants now ultimately of
course she sides with Xavier and chooses
not to assassinate the president
but I'm sorry I choose not to
assassinate Bolivar Trask but in the end
you know I think that that Jennifer
Lawrence was a much better mystique in
the you know in addition to the fact
that Jennifer Lawrence is my home girl
so I'm always gonna side with Jennifer
Lawrence when it comes to a question
like that Cameron oh my god Cameron like
five different questions okay when and
how did the mutants sending Wolverine
back in time develop such powers okay so
it's obvious at this point the Kitty
Pryde was the one that sent Wolverines
mind into the past as far as I
understand it it's not really explained
outright I think it has something to do
with her face shifting abilities and the
fact that a bishop can travel through
time but Bishop didn't have the inherent
ability to travel through time Bishop
had the ability to travel through time
due to technology from his time period
so it's really kind of interesting here
they don't really come out and say you
know her face shifting abilities grant
her the ability to send people through
time they really kind of say well it's
really kind of her ability to phase and
send people into the past by sending
their consciousness and that's really
the only explanation that we get
when when they were explaining it when
Charles Xavier is explaining it she's
talking I'm sorry kitty pryde is talking
about how she can send the conscious and
the consciousness of a person into the
past by a couple days but their mind
really can't handle the stress and their
mind is of cracking and shutting down
you know if they can't go back any
further so it's it's really kind of
weird the way they explain it but it's
not really in Beth I think they could
have done a better job of explaining
that but I felt like it was kind of like
all right we just need a really quick
easy explanation to how it is it
Wolverines gonna go back in time using
the powers of kitty pryde and that's
that and no one's gonna question it you
know because who cares so I'm not really
sure what the logic was behind their
choice to have Katie pried cinnamon in
the past let's see at some point we hear
a familiar major name who turns out to
be someone else please explain why it is
that someone else all right I'm not
really sure what Cameron's referring to
here angel maybe but you know maybe he's
talking about the character angel who
has the same name and in the Marvel
Comics but he's not talking about Warren
Worthington the third so maybe that's
what he's referring to you know that
it's that maybe he's referring to
worrying more than the third but it
actually turns out that it's angel the
girl and then and that would make sense
because we saw Warren Worthington
and x-men last stand and you know the
movies are this one really kind of read
coms x-men Last Stand but I guess maybe
there's kind of a throw out to say hey
you know we still acknowledge the fact
that you know Archangel is still a part
of the Fox movie franchise we just
really haven't had him in a movie since
you know x-men last and I'm not really
sure what it is a cameras referring
through here to which extension people
district are disregard the last stand or
considering Professor X is alive but
others who died in the movie okay so we
haven't really got an explanation like
that I haven't gotten an explanation on
that when the Days of Future past when
when Wolverine is successful in
preventing the assassination of Bulevar
Trask it really retcons everything in
dated in a x-men Last Stand so Jean Grey
as far as I can tell
hasn't really been touched by the
Phoenix force yet she may very well have
but I don't think that she has actually
been touched by the Phoenix force she
looks the way
and the sunset her hair is a very very
dark auburn color but she you know there
was no semblance of like a fire in her
eyes or anything to indicate to us aside
from maybe the similar appearances that
she had been touched by the Phoenix
force in addition Cyclops is alive and
of course Professor X is alive so in
x-men last and they had been killed off
so as far as I understand it by keeping
the assassination of all of our trash
happening really everything that took
place in x-men last stand doesn't count
anymore so everything that happened
after x-men xx2 is non-existent so you
can pretty much just cancel everything
that you saw an x-men last stand now
whether or not that means that leech who
was the child who was able to nullify
powers whether or not that means that he
you simply won't make an appearance or
he doesn't exist at all or anything like
that we don't really know I mean this
was really kind they really kind of told
us that x-men last stand didn't count
any more over this fan of you know a
three or four-minute kind of montage
scene as we were introduced to the fact
that some of the characters have died in
x-men last and were brought back to life
and the movie The Wolverine we see Logan
get his old claws back but in Days of
Future past the metal claws are back
what's the continuity there all right as
I understand it it was simply his mind
that was sitting to the past and so
Wolverines mind from the future was
sitting to his past body and so that was
before he met William Stryker and that
was before William Stryker had bonded
the adamantium to his body and so at
this point in time he still had bone
claws that really seems to be the
continuity that's going on that really
seems to be the explanation I mean just
because of the fact that in terms of his
physical appearance
he's his younger self he doesn't have
gray all on the side of his head or
anything like that so I'm pretty sure
that's what that's what what's going on
in terms of the continuity Rob I pretty
much know who's at the end after the
credits why does he look the way he does
so not powerful and also did the events
that occur deviate everything deviate
everything from what happened originally
through this series like a reboot of
some time okay so we just explained that
in terms of last stand
so everything that took place in x-men 1
and x-men 2 apparently has still taken
place but everything that took place in
x-men last stand doesn't count anymore
in addition I'm assuming that we're just
seeing a younger version of apocalypse
that's really just kind of my thought
here again it was a post-credits scene
it was a minute and a half long and
really all we heard in terms of talk was
a group chanting in Subodh norse so we
have no idea what the context is here we
have no earthly clue what's going on I
would say given the time period it's
just a young version of Apocalypse and
he hasn't quite you know grown into
adulthood yet or anything who was the
guy with a knife and the red paint over
his eyes yeah that that's warpath that's
a James Brown star the Sun I guess the
younger brother of John proud star who
was Thunderbird one of the original
x-men as part as part of giant-sized
edgemon what are your thoughts on the
lack of Stanley and this movie um to me
does it really matter I'm not really a
stickler for Stanley appearing in Marvel
level films I mean I don't care really
that he didn't appear it doesn't really
matter to me because his appearances it
really just kind of like hey I'm Stanley
you know just letting you guys know that
me and Jack covery were the one that
created all this stuff you know
I'm actually really kind of glad to see
that Chris Claremont appeared in the
movie because Chris Claremont was the
writer of the Days of Future past and
here's the thing to bear in mind Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby started the x-men but
Chris Claremont revolutionized the x-men
and he the the exponent you guys are
most familiar with the x-men that you
guys are most likely thinking of when
you think of x-men in the comics you're
thinking of Chris Claremont x-men and so
Chris Claremont is really kind of the
quintessential x-men writer and almost
anyone who's a fan of
x-men will tell you that Chris Claremont
wrote some of the best stories involving
the x-men so I was really more happy to
see that Chris Claremont appeared then
Stanley and I think that was intentional
you know especially because like we said
Chris Claremont was the one who wrote
the Days of Future Passed story I was do
you think Quicksilver should have been
included in the movie more I think his
role in the movie was about right he was
really kind of a supporting character I
feel like if he had appeared any more
than he did it would have just kind of
been Quicksilver being shoved in our
faces it really would have been
interesting
you know for the purpose that he served
for the role he played it was just
perfect for him he was really just an
assistant to help get Magneto out of
jail or out of the the prison that he
was being held in and the center of the
Pentagon you know I don't think that he
really needed to have any more of a role
than that
it basically erased all the previous
ones do you think that was a good idea
yeah
x-men Last Stand was terrible that was a
horrible movie it was one of the worst
movies I've seen in a long time and and
it really destroyed for the most part my
faith and Fox being able to make a good
Marvel based film now this movie kind of
restored that a little bit I mean I'm
you know of course I'll always side with
the Marvel Cinematic Universe just
because you have the creators of comic
books making their own movies so you
know I mean it's it would be like me you
know as a t-shirt maker being contracted
to make wooden tables you know I make
t-shirts why would I make wooden tables
now if you come to me and say Rob I want
you to make a t-shirt I'll make the best
t-shirt you've ever seen but I have no
business making wooden tables it's
really kind of what's going on here
Marvel makes comic books and they're
making movies about the comics they make
it really you know kind of stands to
reason to me that they would do a much
better job than Fox but nonetheless some
kind of digressing here um yes nothing
was a good idea that x-men last stand
was scared last time was cancelled
because now we see characters like Beast
coming back and we can really kind of
change everything we can really kind of
set a whole new path for these
characters and we don't have to worry
about x-men last and kind of getting in
the way so